um yeah
um yeah so
um so I should say this talk May lack
the uh let's say the Polish that you
definitely absolutely would have gotten
if I gave my talk on Wednesday
and it's just too many you know typos
mathematical errors jokes that fall flat
we're all things that were going to get
fixed
so and I was talking to uh to have one
of my grad students at some point I was
telling him that I think the thing that
changes the most between when your
faculty when you're a grad student is
your willingness to stand up in front of
a room with something of a tenuous grasp
of exactly what you're going to say but
at least broad Strokes so on that note
today i'm going to talk about an almost
linear time algorithm for approximate
Max and undirected graphs
um and I wrote its multi-commodity
generalizations I'm probably going to
just State their generalizations and
then not really talk about them uh just
because I think timing wise it's not
going to quite fit
um I should kind of stress the
collaborators who are all Healthcare
actually where's random Rhythm yes so uh
this is Joint work with uh with yintat
laurenzo and Aaron
um I should uh and it also kind of
overlaps topically with what Jonah was
going to talk about Jonah is going to be
shuffled later in the week and I kind of
just want to I guess take this as an
opportunity to publicly say that I know
I think I'm lucky enough to be in a
topic right now with several really
exceptional recent grad students or grad
students and so um you should all take
they're all physically here right now I
strongly encourage you to take advantage
of talking to them because they're all
great
okay sales pitch aside
um okay so let me give you the overview
of what we're going to talk about so the
results I'm going to talk about by the
way is actually essentially the same
result as what Jonah was going to talk
about from a dual perspective so we have
fairly uh fairly different techniques
that get to roughly the same place
what so I think that's um I was going to
slightly cut down on my intra material
in the sliding slide between now and
then so I'm going to Breeze through this
fairly quickly if I breathe through it
so quickly that I say nothing or say
things so quickly that they don't make
any sense to stop me
um so what I'm going to talk about today
is an approach for several of the basic
problems in algorithmic graph Theory Max
flow Min cut multi-commodity flow
maximum concurrent flow and I think most
people in the room probably don't need a
huge amount of discussion of the
motivation so I'm just going to say
they're important as my broad motivation
for Max flow they have shown up a lot in
both practice and in theory and also
maybe my motivation on it more is that
their study has really been broadly one
of the things that's been driving a lot
of the general theory of optimization
that they're very good test cases for
new ideas and to some extent I think if
you make something go faster with these
you have to it's a good way to know that
you actually sort of have learned
something and I think that's my main
motivation here is that it really does
isolate certain technical hurdles that
you have to get past in order to improve
a running time on this they tend to
reappear
so it's also used as a subroutine in a
lot of other settings
um and
um what we're going to do today is we're
going to talk about how to use this sort
of new general approach to break several
barriers on the running time that had
stood for a pretty long time beforehand
um I'm gonna Focus today on Max flow and
I'm going to very briefly discuss it of
how to generalize it my discussion is
roughly going to be and then you
generalize it
um it's not good it's going to be a very
brief version a very brief
um and for the rest of the talk there's
some assumptions I'm going to make for
this talk that I'll make for convenience
and there's some some you know just
because like I don't want to deal with
it and there's some assumptions I'm
going to make because my results are
things I completely don't know how to do
if I don't for the rest of the talk
today all of the graphs will be
undirected and this is because I really
don't know how to do it for directed
graphs um I know how to do something for
directed graphs which is gonna
the essentially the the strongest thing
you can do without saying something new
um and so I would really love to know
how to do all this with directed graphs
and today I'm going to talk about
undirected graphs I think the directed
graph question is a very good question I
would have a lot of pretty strong strong
applications I should mention that uh
later in the day uh we're gonna see one
of the first maybe the first in a very
long time ways of improving the directed
graph case which will be at one o'clock
130 something when Alexander talks uh
later this afternoon we're going to see
so this so today I'm going to give a
linear time algorithm for undirected
he's going to give a better than three
halves algorithm for an almost linear
time sorry but you're shaking your head
you're not doing that
oh what are you gonna talk about
um
so he's going to surprise us with
something that's even better than what
I'm announcing
um
okay so in any case he could talk about
what I'm saying that's almost as good
okay so uh today I'm talking about Max
flow I'm going to give this slide
largely just to fix notation so the
we're going to have a graph throughout
the talk it will be V and e v will be
vertices e will be edges and will always
be the number of vertices and M will be
the number of edges I'm going to make
all my graphs unweighted that one is
just for convenience the undirected is
because I really can't not make that
assumption that I waited is just because
I don't want to write weights and uh
there'll be capacities which will be the
weights that I'm going to now call one
and uh I
popped on this slide from Alexander at
some point you'll notice that some of
these slides look a little look his
slides and you just know that it's me
ripping off him and not vice versa if he
uses any of them
um okay so uh this is the max flow
problem you have capacities on your
edges you have a source and a sink you
want to send stuff from your source to
your sink
um you're allowed to send things over
edges it's undirected so the capacities
are bi-directional uh Whenever there has
to be flow conservation at every vertex
so whatever goes into a Vertex has to
come out and except at the source in the
sink you want to send as much as you can
from the source in the tank sync without
sending more than you're supposed to
over any Edge
um okay so uh note um you could talk
about the flow in is going to be equal
flow out everywhere but at the source
and sync the flow out of the source or
into the sink those are the same number
and are equal to the answer
um and
uh we're gonna
uh I guess I said that on out loud
already okay and so this is our goal our
goal broadly is just get the highest
value so the value of a flow is the
amount of flow sent from source to sync
and our goal is going to be to make it
as big as possible without exceeding the
capacities
um so what we're going to talk about now
is the approximate version of the
problem so here the goal is going to be
I give you a graph I promise you that it
has opt as the actual answer to the
maximum amount of flow you can send from
s to T without exceeding the capacities
um and our goal is going to be to give a
flow that's within a multiplicative one
minus Epsilon of the optimal answer
Okay so
I'm going to kind of sketch the running
time the running time there's been a lot
of work on this over the last 60 years
that I'm not going to really summarize
uh and
um instead I'm just going to kind of
jump to the more recent stuff so today
I'm going to talk about undirected
graphs and one of my steps on a
proximate optimal flow which at least by
narrowing it to this lets me narrow down
the list of work to summarize for that
the best previous running time was a
paper by several papers by people who
were in various subsets are in the room
right now
um and that was uh something like I
wrote m n to the one-third so the
interesting case for these problems I
want to say is roughly the sparse graph
case you should think that
um for when you're doing one minus
Epsilon approximate things the sparse
graph case is really where the technical
challenge is because you can often
sparse your way out of sparsify your way
to something a little better
not quite this good not quite a it's not
exactly a reduction but it's almost a
reduction for the cut problems it is and
so roughly you should think m equals n
and I'm just going to say this is four
thirds as an exponent and the previous
best was four thirds
um and today what we're gonna end for
maximum multi-commodity flow it was also
four thirds
um assuming you have a constant number
of Commodities so it was m to the Four
Thirds with a polynomial dependence on
the number of Commodities and one over
Epsilon again you should think about our
multi-commodity flow results in the
regime where K is smallish
um it there are better algorithms if K
is something like Theta of and or root n
you should think of K as a large
constant possibly for these results it's
going to be poly and K and we're not
going to worry about The Valleys
um and the main results for today are
going to be how to do all of these
problems in
um almost linear time so when I say
almost linear uh what I mean by that is
um something like m to the one plus a
little o of one uh so uh Dan and Chiang
wise have been using nearly linear to
mean M poly log n and so I couldn't use
nearly so I decided to make almost
anything I'm gonna stick with it almost
is going to be one plus a little L of
one it's not quite polylog it's like two
to the root log n so it's better than
one plus Epsilon for any Epsilon
um and uh the multi-commodity flow
result it's actually not even a terrible
dependence on K but I do suspect it
could be made into a better one
okay so those are the results I'll talk
about are there any questions
okay
so
um I should mention that you know
because this thing is a subroutine in
other algorithms you can use this
essentially with no new thinking to get
better algorithms for some other
problems basically by plugging it in as
black box so for example this one
actually if you plug it into a paper
that Jonah wrote that you can get a
better root log approximate sparsus
cutter balance cut algorithm out of this
among others okay so I do want to
mention and this is actually a very
convenient timing for you to mention
that um so the what I'm talking about
today for the single commodity case uh
Jonah was actually going to talk about
another approach to get to the roughly
the same point so he was going to give
another
um I think the way he was doing it it
might have a slightly different Epsilon
dependence but it could be made into the
same Epsilon dependence and probably so
roughly you should think it's a similar
result but he's going to come at it from
a dual perspective and it's
um it really is beautiful work the way
he's doing it so you'll see that today
we're going to construct a primal object
of flow and he has a beautiful approach
to avoid constructing a flow but instead
working only with the cut side of things
and it in some sense can be if you write
it the right way you could view it as a
dual version of this algorithm and that
actually comes with certain
simplifications that are really nice so
that by the way as an organizer I'll now
tell you will be later in the week the
scheduling is getting nailed down as we
speak but later in the week you'll see
sort of a different route to similar
results
uh
let me now kind of start running through
the ideas here and
um what I'm going to do I'm going to
give background tools and limitations I
kind of want to stress here that what
I'm not doing is trying to give related
work so I'm what I'm giving here is sort
of the tools that motivated this work
that we kind of Drew from and sometimes
the actual algorithm that I'm describing
here was largely motivated partially by
the existing tools and also partially by
sort of the things that didn't quite
work with them so a lot of the new
technical pieces of this were motivated
by limitations of things we wanted to
use for similar purposes and so what I
want to do now is run through kind of
the basic background tools that we're
going to either use or not use as we go
on
um okay so
um I should say just as a general you
know related work thing that for the
first couple decades of its study uh
Maxwell algorithms tended to be largely
at least the fastest ones tended to be
combinatorial and deterministic
um and they culminated in uh the result
by Goldberg and Rao which is a long one
to read but if you were to take my
Convention of n is about equal to M uh
it's m to the three halves
um and uh you should note that there's
no Epsilon in that and
I would love to make mine look like that
too so these uh and uh you know kind of
recently we recently needing something
ranging depending how you read the
sentence something ranging from two to
thirty years
uh recently these techniques have been
augmented by randomization sort of
techniques from numerical methods and
iterative
techniques for linear algebra and
scientific Computing and continuous
optimization and I think this is a very
exciting general direction which is that
you'll see that a lot of the talks in
this Workshop actually have been drawing
kind of
very extensively on ideas coming from
the scientific Computing side of things
and I guess since I wasn't here to give
the opening remarks uh in my opinion box
I would have mentioned that I think it's
actually a very exciting time for kind
of both Fields because the two fields
are very very successfully drawing from
each other you know if you were to
unwind some of the algorithms in these
talks you'll see that they're sort of
using combinatorial techniques to solve
uh continuous problems and using the
continuous problems to solve the
combinatorial once again and I think
it's a very nice kind of coming together
of the ideas
um and I'm going to rip off some of them
and again I'm not going to try to give a
literature review uh I'm just going to
try to give sort of the motivating tools
that will show up in the in the actual
algorithm I'm presenting all right so
today I'm going to really focus on
single commodity until maybe the last 30
seconds of the talk
um and the first tool that really kind
of is the starting point for some of
this is sparsification so as
parsification goes back to bankster and
Carter and uh you know roughly what it
says is I give you a dense graph and I'm
going to
almost answer questions about it while
only solving problems on a smart graph
so I'll start with the dense graph G and
for this you should think of M is much
bigger than n and what bengshrin cargo
showed was that you can find a sparse
graph G Prime where sparse is going to
mean something like npali login
and it's going to have the following
properties one is that all cuts are
within a multiplicative one plus or
minus Epsilon of what they were in the
original graph
um note the multiplicative is what makes
this non-trivial like if I were to say
additive you know Epsilon N squared or
something then this you could really do
by random sampling pretty easily but if
what you want to do but here it says you
have to get the sparse Cuts right um so
if this cut is small you have to be a
lot more precise on it and
um and the impressive Point Property
here is that you can do this with
something like n log n over Epsilon
squared edges
um you can actually do it with fewer uh
which uh if somehow in the last minute
we manage pressure damage giving a talk
he can argue that you can erase the
login but not quickly enough for the
algorithmic applications here uh and uh
so today we're going to kind of forget
the existence of papers that give
stronger guarantees because we're going
to stick to ones we can do very quickly
and so the results here is you can get
all the cuts approximately right with
the graph whose average degrees just log
n over Epsilon squared
and also crucial for algorithmic
applications is that you can do this
very quickly you can find them in time
that's
nearly linear Which is less than almost
linear and that's acceptable for our
application
okay so
um how does it work the way it works is
broadly speaking it is random sampling
again if I said that it was just m
Square Epsilon N squared additive
guarantees and you really could just
sample your way to this result pretty
easily uh the problem is is that you
have to get the small Cuts right and if
you blindly sample a cut with three
edges you may well miss it and so if you
have a lot of small Cuts then random
sampling naively won't work so what they
do is they choose very carefully good
probabilities that weight the important
things more than the unimportant things
and then they do independent random
sampling over the edges now what's good
about this is that it's super fast it's
you know super clean and simple
it's flow
to a one plus or minus Epsilon where
essentially you can take any running
time you want and erase all the M's and
write in ends and some tildas oh by the
way I'm going to put tildas over O's to
mean up to poly login enters
may also use that to hide
one plus little little of one factors I
cannot make promises on that based on
the
length of time that has passed since
last I look at the looked at these
slides so
um okay so the uh
the good news is that you can actually
get the cut value correct right because
the maximum and cut theorem says that
the max flow and the Min cut have the
same numerical value and so if every cut
is approximated then what you can do is
sample your graph down to this much
Spicer graph find the value of the Min
cut which is also the value of the max
flow and that has to be the value of the
max flow in the original graph now the
bad news for this is okay sorry more
good news the good news is that it's
very powerful right it lets you
completely blindly replace your graph
with a sparse graph and then all your
items become ends the limitation of it
is that you only get the value of the
flow you don't get the actual flow
itself
and this one is a real one like you
might think I don't know something with
the word dual and it should all work out
but it doesn't like it actually is
complicated and the reason is that in
some sense it's much easier to sample
than to unsample right the reason the
cuts are preserved is that you're
starting with these with some dense
graphs and you're assigning
probabilities somehow and then random
sampling and so then when an edge
appears in your sparsified graph it's
kind of standing in for a bunch of edges
in the original graph it's one
representative of some class and so
um if I gave you Cuts you know that
numerically everything works out but if
I actually try to take a flow on the
sample graph it's not we don't know how
to route the flow from the sample graph
back onto the original graph without
because this one at you know the one
Edge is supposed to stand for a whole
bunch of edges but in a way that's
fairly subtly kind of wound up in the
global properties of the graph
um okay so that's sort of the main
technical challenge that keeps us from
using this the other thing is of course
we don't know how to do sparse graphs uh
in linear time but I should mention this
really is a real one and like uh up
until the work this work in Jonah's work
there were long-standing gaps between
the best Max flow approximate algorithms
and Min St cut approximation algorithms
roughly some you know you cannot trade
all of the M's into n's that was why I
have like an m n to the one-third
instead of an M plus n to the four
thirds you know this actually was there
uh up until the present were because you
couldn't you really there was something
you can do with recursion that will make
it doable to get some result out of it
but you really can't just kind of uh
blindly apply to scheme because you
really don't know how to take a flow in
one graph and get one in the other
okay so that's our first Tool uh the
second tool we're going to work with is
iterative methods and electrical Flows
In linear systems
um
I mentioned before that prior to this
there were things that were I'm going to
call Four Thirds ish algorithms for uh
for Max flow and there were two classes
of them that actually did something
fairly different but they both relied on
a primitive they both relied on the
Primitive that lets you compute
um very quickly what I'm calling
electrical flows and so what electrical
flows are is you take your graph you're
just gonna take your edges and you're
gonna pretend they're electrical
resistant resistors
and then you're gonna you then you're
gonna use the fact that it turns out due
to work of well Dan Shanghai and then
later work by another non-negligible
subset of people in the room uh you can
very efficiently solve these electrical
flow problems you can take electrical
circuits and figure out what electricity
will do in nearly linear time and so
this gives you this powerful primitive
for probing the structure of a graph
this is using laplacian linear system
solvers and
um you know but these what these
algorithms did was find ways of sort of
leveraging this to get better and better
approximations so the electrical flow on
a graph is not the max flow right we
want to move minimizing L2 one's
minimizing L Infinity those aren't the
same thing so what you do instead but
both algorithms do with different
approaches to doing so is they solve an
electrical flow problem they then find
that some edges are flowing too much and
they fix it so in one of the algorithms
they take the edges flowing too much and
kind of hike the resistance up the
others try to reroute the flow that's
being overflowed
um and that's kind of the general way
that they work
um and
I should point out that both of them you
know they're four-thirds type algorithms
the four-thirds is linear time per
iteration and uh n to the one-third
iterations the uh and I'm gonna drop
words like almost in nearly occasionally
nearly linear time and nearly and third
into the one third time
um and I should say that both of them in
some sense they really were rude and
iteration algorithm that were then uh
used good iterative techniques to make
that root out into an end to the one
third
um one of them used uh accelerated
gradient descent methods like finasterov
and the other one used sort of a careful
combinatorial analysis of what happens
in electrical circuits
um and but that root n was really kind
of there like you could
um do some work on your iterative
methods to turn a square root into a
cube root but there was an actual
problem with it's it that was as far as
those techniques go that's what
acceleration gets you and this was a
really kind of intrinsic limitation of
the techniques so what is the good news
the way that both these worked was they
took this crude primitive sort of
solving the problem well right like
stopping electrical flows which is not
what you want and I don't know if you do
something badly I guess do it over and
over and over
um is maybe a bad lesson to be conveying
but it works and so they do is they tell
you a way of taking sort of crude
algorithms that approximately solve your
problem and if they meet the right
guarantees you can sort of iteratively
use them to get better algorithms to get
better approximations by calling them
many times
um the limitations on this
um is that really the running time of
this strongly strongly comes from the
quality of your crude algorithm so it's
actually not too bad in
oversimplification just to say that all
of these iterative methods they have
some number that dictates the number of
iterations and in all the ones I can
think of at least it is explicitly a
function of the crudeness of your crude
algorithm so the root end that I said
before comes from the fact that
electrical flows can be that L2 at L
Infinity can differ by a root n that you
can have something you know that that's
that's the uh the ingredient that shows
up and it's really kind of intrinsic
um and they're sort of strongly dictated
by the quality of their crude algorithms
and the crude algorithms that we're
using these electrical flows there
really is a root end difference you know
if you try to put a cube inside a sphere
inside a cube you really do get that
root n it's there and so
um okay so that was our second tool and
the good news was that the iterative
methods really gave us a lot to work
with I should also mention that the
rubric used for constructing the nearly
linear time solvers
um is strongly motivated it strongly
motivates some of the technical pieces
of what we're about to talk about so if
you know those solvers you'll recognize
a lot of recurring themes okay so that's
tool too tool three is oblivious
rounding which um
here this morning with
let me very quickly do this because I
don't know if everyone was but roughly
speaking the motivation of oblivious
writing and I'm going to do this in
again kind of
embarrassing oversimplification but it
would be the extent to which I'll need
it for need it for the talk which is
that you want to Route traffic between
many pairs of users say on the internet
that's a good motivating application and
I guess since we're in a theory crowd I
should probably Define my terms so I
should mention by the way that if I had
time to do this talk I would like update
my hilarious meme joke to more recent
ones but I'd have to find out what the
more recent memes are okay so in case
you're not comfortable with the internet
if you actually look at recent empirical
analyzes it's roughly a finite capacity
medium for sending pictures of cats who
can't spell
um and
um
yeah so this is this would have been
much more funny if I actually knew what
a recent meme was and have time to
update it uh okay and
um it's also I should say has found some
other applications as well and the
um what you want to do is you want to
route you know traffic between Pairs so
it's a multi-commodity flow problem but
what you don't want to do is solve a
size of the internet uh problem every
iteration right like if you wanted to
you know we'd know how to solve the
multi-commodity flow problems it's poly
n by the end of the talk it's almost
linear then but if you had to do that
every time you had to write a packet on
the internet then that would be very bad
um and uh so instead what we're going to
do is try to solve this without actually
doing something quite so complicated and
I want to kind of mention this is going
to show up later in the talk there's a
couple views of view ways of viewing
routing you could view it as a
distribution of paths so if I give you a
pair of vertices s and t you could think
of a flow between them it's just a
probability distribution over pads
and I'll go back and forth between the
two
um okay and so
that's your routing scheme and with the
oblivious writings team says is that you
instead of every packet you know if
you're able to kind of adaptively decide
based on like if S1 can look at what S2
and snt2 are doing and use that to
figure out how to route traffic then you
actually can do better you know
multi-commodity flow problems you can
actually do better than solving
sequences of individual flow problems
um and what oblivious routing does is it
says that's expensive what we're going
to do instead is at the beginning of
time we're going to figure out a routing
scheme which is going to correspond to a
specific flow for every pair of vertices
and you know in the actual routing sense
think it was the probability
distribution over you know every packet
randomly chooses one of these paths you
decide it once and then whenever I wrap
traffic between a pair of vertices the
flow is determined like I you know I
don't know the demands in advance but
given any set of Demands I take the
demand between S1 and T1 I multiply it
by the flow that I actually had fixed
and advanced and used it right and this
does seem to inhere a substantial loss
problem very plausibly right like it is
true and quite plausible that knowing
all of your traffic will let you route
individually better
um and
the uh this is something you've been
studied for a while for specific graphs
and I might batch the history here I
think I have it right is it goes back to
the 80s for specific graphs and you know
the right measure for what we're talking
about and sort of what's been used in
the literature is the competitive ratio
so the idea is that you have this
optimal routing scheme the one that says
I fixed my demands and then given those
demands I'll solve a multi-commodity
flow problem get the right answer
or I can take my oblivious routing which
says I'm only allowed to use a fixed
route for every set of Demands that's
fixed in advance and then the demands
show up and then I use the scheme and
the competitive ratio is just the worst
case over all possible input demands of
the ratio between the congestion so
congestion is the maximum ratio between
the amount you send over an edge and
what you're allowed to send over the
edge so it's capacity so flow over
capacity the competitive ratio is going
to be the worst case over all possible
demands of this ratio
and in a what I thought was a really
truly surprising result
um
members of this room uh have uh that's
where this was talked about a fast way
of doing this was talked about this
morning but it turns out that actually
every graph has an oblivious routing
scheme with a competitive ratio that's
only log n
um apriari I don't think n to the one
third is obvious you know like
um right like
Ruden I guess I gave earlier in the talk
uh you can do if you work a little bit
with electrical flows n to the one third
non-obvious right and like this is one
of those theorems that I think when you
first see it and I probably would have
been more likely to bet that it was
false before betting it was true until
it was true
um and the good news on that is that I
said we want to use crude Primitives to
get better Primitives and this is a
pretty good crude primitive right like
that Ruden I was talking about now looks
like a log
um so
um if I just want log approximations
I've already solved my problem uh the
good that's the good news the
limitations of this though for using it
in our algorithmic setting are actually
pretty substantial so one of them is
it's way too slow so or you know there's
a certain logical unwinding here
um in that uh the talk before this used
Jonas paper uh as a primitive but um you
know the
um without using a faster Max flow
algorithm the way that these
multi-commod these um the way to get a
good oblivious routing scheme is it's
much slower than Max flow and until this
morning or the talk from this morning
which case it was only slightly slower
than Max flow but they all use max flow
things as Primitives or multi-commodity
flow problems with Primitives uh prior
to these works the running time was
something between N squared and N cubed
depending on how you count
um and like depending on how you read
the papers and it was definitely not
nearly linear like it was this is a
harder problem than Max flow and so
because it's solving all you know doing
a multi-commodity flow kind of question
and so it was much much slower so you
can't use it as a primitive
um and then the other problem was that
it really it's
you know but I said that it's crude
algorithms become uncrewed algorithms
that was a slight lie you need
not just crude algorithms like you need
sort of crude algorithms with some
flexibility to turn them into better
ones this gave like a really an
intrinsic log uh the log is there and
um it's really not clear how to use it a
couple times and get turn that log into
a constant
um okay so those were the sort of basic
pieces so just to kind of put them back
up here so just to really super
summarize uh sparsification good news
was sparse grass become dense graphs for
approximation bad news it's really not
clear how to use this to actually get
flows and also it's you still have to
solve the sparse graph case
um tool number two was iterative methods
and the good news is that they really do
one is the electrical stuff gives us a
very powerful primitive to work with
graphs right you can solve this
complicated Global problem in nearly
linear time uh the bad news is one is
that
um well really it's that it's there's
really an intrinsic root end in this
electrical flow primitive
um and the last one was oblivious
routing which has its good news is it
gives you all your log approximations
that you want the bad news is that it's
slower than the thing we're trying to
use it for and it's not clear how to
improve the log to a constant in
specific cases
okay before I go into the details on
anything that's turning are there any
questions
okay so uh I said before this kind of my
talk was motivated by the existing tools
so each of our new technical Primitives
roughly come out of one of these tools
so for sparsification what we're going
to introduce are flow specifiers which
is a term that other people have used
for other things so this just comes with
a general warning for us what they're
going to be is basically they're going
to be the thing that Venture cargo gives
us but they're going to come with a
routing scheme
um so they'll preserve all the cuts up
to a one plus or minus Epsilon but
they'll also come with a way of not
losing too much and routing your flows
and your sparse graphs back into your
dense graphs so they'll come with a
technique for taking flows in the sparse
things and producing flows back in the
originals which was our original problem
um tool number two is the iterative
methods really were maxed out if you use
L2 so we're not going to use L2 and so
we're going to talk about sort of
non-euclidean gradient descent schemes
which are not really new they're maybe
newly packaged in our paper but
um they're we're using some of the
things that are equivalent to fairly
well-known techniques in iterative
methods but the new kind of part of this
is that we're going to show how to use
these uh L Infinity descent techniques
to convert an oblivious routing
algorithm into a Fast Max flow algorithm
where the number of times you call the
oblivious routing algorithm grows with
the competitive ratio
um I want to mention the kind of an
ideological point which was that you
should note that was kind of interesting
about this and it's you can read it into
in the linear system solvers and into
the previous maxflow works as well is
that somehow what we're doing is we're
using the graph structure to actually
construct good algebraic objects and if
you read as we read on you'll see that
what we're really doing is by using this
oblivious rat where we're really using
the oblivious routing schemes for is to
get a better parametrization of flows on
the graph so instead of parameterizing
flows by edges and vertices we're
parameterizing them by something more
complicated coming from the abilities
routing scheme and the win is that we
actually build this oblivious routing
scheme obliviously we built it using the
graph like we actually learned before
just we fixed what we're gonna how we're
going to represent our objects using the
structural properties and that kind of
gave us the leverage to get better
competitive ratios
um and then uh the limitations of the
last war that it was slow I kind of
already mentioned the not clear how to
use that will come back to this but for
the slow we're going to make it not slow
so we're going to show how to give it's
not quite going to be the polylog uh
that one would hope for it's going to be
an ending to the little o of one
competitive oblivious routing algorithm
um and we now do know that you can then
use this to feed it back into an
oblivious routing construction and you
can use this to solve Max flow problems
which you can then use to get new
Bluetooth routing algorithms uh but you
know here we're going to construct a
slightly weaker competitiveness
guarantee uh it's going to be a little
bit worse than polylog
okay
uh let me now fill in the details a
little more so again capacities will be
one just you know for Simplicity and
we're going to talk about congestion
minimization instead of Max flow so
we're just basically going to divide by
the answer so instead of trying to send
as much as we can without congesting
anything we're going to say
um we're going to say you're going to
send one unit of flow and minimize the
max congestion if you then you know uh
take that number and take one over it
and scale by it you get the other
problem it's just a rescaling that's
more convenient for a iterative setup
and our algorithm is going to just
basically be like all editor methods
start with something simple and improve
it so we're going to start with some
initial flow F0 that we're going to get
without too much work and then we're
going to iteratively try to reduce its
congestion
um and the super high level view of this
is we're going to have nth a little of
one iterations and each iteration is
going to take the number of edges in the
graph time something that's n value of
one so two to the root log like they're
both going to be the so this is the
actual number it's 2 to the O of as to
the square root of log n log log n uh I
know the way to think about that if it
looks like a lot of symbols is the log
of it is square root of log so
polynomials have log being polylog being
log and
um you know log things have log log so
this is kind of halfway between the two
so it's better than any polynomial
um and each iteration is going to take
almost linear time and we'll have an
almost constant number of iterations
and the approach is going to have two
main parts
uh one is the iterative scheme which is
going to be a sort of General gradient
descent technique
um and we're going to use that to show
how to reduce the problem to
constructing a matrix with some nice
algebraic properties
um and then once we have uh then so the
iterative scheme is going to let us
reduce to constructing a projection
Matrix then we're going to construct the
projection Matrix uh constructing the
projection Matrix is going to have a
very easy reduction to oblivious routing
or at least a fairly easy one it's going
to be fit on a slide
um and then the real work is gonna oh
this is coming and constructing the
oblivious routing scheme that actually
has the properties we need that can be
done fast enough with good enough
congestion
um and
um I might be missing a tool here if you
look at this too carefully right so the
way that you might not see flow of
sparse with fires yet so the way that
we're actually going to construct the
oblivious routing scene which is where
the sort of technical core of the paper
happens is you're going to chop the
graph into smaller and smaller pieces
and recursively solve show how to reduce
getting an oblivious routing scheme on a
graph to getting an oblivious routing
scheme on some number of smaller graphs
and uh hopefully make your own currents
work
um and the uh the place where we use
flow sparsification is inside of that
we're going to use that in our process
of taking complicated graphs and
reducing routing on them to routing on
simple graphs
um okay so creating the center for
General Norms is my first piece and this
one it's um I mentioned that I've stolen
pictures from students and farmer
students here this one I did not steal
from Alexander because I stole it from
intap and uh the goal here is to
minimize the convex function so this is
just a general descent scheme and uh you
know General iterative methods for
everything are start with a point and
improve it so General iterative method
start with some point x0 iteratively
find some Delta X that makes your answer
better and repeat
um
the uh
um the uh
standard gradient the stem technique is
really an L2 gradient descent
so L2 grading descent which is usually
just gradient descent is you um start at
some point at zero and repeatedly I
wrote a complicated looking expression
but you take the gradient and what is
the gradient really doing what it's
really doing
is uh minimizing over some ball
um where the ball is an L2 ball a local
approximation of your function right so
the main points in gradient descent you
take your convex function you
approximate it by a linear term and some
other stuff
you hope your other stuff is small and
then you optimize your linear term over
some low you know your linear
approximation over some local
neighborhood where the neighborhood here
is a ball of radius are and because
calculus is super nice and L2 it turns
out that that is just the answer to this
map this optimization problem minimize V
Dot X over a ball happens to be in the
direction of V but that's a coincidence
based on L2
um really you should think of gradient
descent as linearly approximate your
function and optimize it over a small
neighborhood where neighborhood is L2
um and this is great descent
um and all we're going to do here is
somehow L2 is really not well suited for
Maxwell you know Max flow is
intrinsically an L Infinity problem
minimize the max congestion
um that Cube and sphere thing that I
offhandedly semi explained before really
is there and it really is a rude end
right like if you're trying to solve an
L Infinity problem and you're trying to
approximate it with balls there is a
root end floating around that's hard to
get rid of so instead we're going to do
an L Infinity gradient descent procedure
and the only change is just that we're
gonna
um replace the two arm with an Infinity
Norm
still you're going to still approximate
it with a function with its gradient the
gradient is the right way to write a
function as a linear function plus some
junk it's not a norm dependence
assertion so uh you're still going to
approximate your function with this
local linearization but now you're going
to optimize it over little cubes instead
of over little spheres
um and that for our case will do a lot
better roughly the point is going to be
that you know you want to you want to
make your local approximation you should
think of this as your crude primitive is
solve something approximately over this
local neighborhood and you lose that
root n by approximating everything by L2
norms and by balls and so our first kind
of main reduction here is we're going to
work with L Infinity Norms which will if
we really could solve these local
problems do a lot better because they're
a lot more similar to the flow problem
we're trying to solve and that's why
that's crude crude approximation so
um yeah as I said before iterative
methods their running time depends on
the quality of the pieces and so here uh
we need to put in some numbers
um the things that matter are
essentially you want to know how
the far you can go before your linear
approximation stops working right so
buried in this somewhere is essentially
you know the right scale is you sort of
draw a little box and see that's how far
you can go before your linear
approximation is no longer useful and
you want to figure out how many boxes
there are to fill up your region of
where your answer could be so what we
need is a radius of the starting area
and a step size like quantity so
formally what you get is you get we're
gonna have some radius R that's the
infinity Norm distance between your
starting point and an Optimum and you're
going to have a lipsticks constant which
is going to dictate how far you can go
before your approximation stops being
useful so the lip hits constant you want
the lip chips constant of the gradient
that's saying how quickly the gradient
changes as you move over some box if you
actually write out what you need it
turns out that you know previously it
was an L2 lipsticks constant really two
was the Dual of two so the right way to
for this sort of thing the right lip
fits constant is you want to look at how
far you can go in Infinity Norm uh and
compare that to the L1 Norm change of
the gradient roughly is because one is
the Dual alarm to Infinity here the
gradient is just the Dual adapter that
you get directly differentiating yes
um like sort of there that's somehow
yeah
I don't understand this um the
the Infinity case is the the function is
is a gradient only locally once you
cross and you you switch to a different
constraint then
the the information you had from the
gradient is no longer useful at all so
you need to pick your rectangle or your
Cube correctly so that you don't move
into an area where
um right so a couple things one is that
so I should say we're smoothing stuff
out so everything will have a gradient
you know so we round the corners out so
at least there's a well-defined gradient
although possibly just uh for Simplicity
you know we we're going to use we're
going to smooth things and use an actual
gradient scheme and then
um you know right now I'm defining a
parameter of the iterative method to be
the lip shits constant and you know
compared to the radius the extent to
which if I just blindly draw a box and
take a step the extent to which that you
know
the extent to which that can actually
what you described can happen the extent
to which you can go a short distance and
then have your gradient completely
change is what the lip shit's constant
captures if the lipstick's constant is
bad then what you're describing can
happen and the goal of our setup is
going to be to construct
um is going to be able to construct the
right functions and parametration so the
lipsticks constantly good so you're
right the you know our priority this
could be terrible it often is so what
we're going to do but we're going to
actually construct an object so that the
Ellipsis constant is well bounded and
here what I'm saying is that if I gave
you just these two numbers delicious
constant and the radius you can use that
to construct a bound on the iterations
and then we're going to try to construct
Primitives so that those iteration
bounds are actually good
does that make sense yeah
so uh you can do some algebra and you
can convince yourself that actually the
guarantee you get out of this
um
you can get the guarantee that sort of
your uh your objective function minus
the optimal objective function this is
the iteration bound you get for the sake
of this talk what matters here is uh the
numerator or polynomial
L and r squared it doesn't really matter
those are the right polynomials but we
don't just need their polynomials the
denominator is K which is the number of
iterations so you know to get this says
that ever that's the rate at which your
error improves so if you want to get
your error to be factored and smaller
you take n times many iterations
um okay so that's our setup and so now
really we're going to come down to
finding things so that L and R aren't
terrible
um okay so that's how we're going to get
to projections so get so so far what
I've done is just given very general
generalities but iterative methods now
let's talk about how we're actually
going to make ones that work
um so first let me just do a little bit
of massaging of our problem to put into
a form that's actually metabolism so
this is our actual problem we want to
minimize the congestion which is just
the I've made all my capacities one so I
don't have to write capacities here
um in which case it really is just the
infinity Norm otherwise I'd put some
diagonal matrices in the right places
um and so now the idea is I want to
minimize over all flows which you think
of as vectors in the edge space that
actually I wrote just routes the demands
that means our flows about the demands
like they meet all the constraints
they're supposed to want to minimize the
infinity norm and
you know so we're going to do is we're
gonna turn this in to start with some
initial flow that wraps the demands and
then we're going to add a circulation so
this is kind of why we scaled it all
down was that instead of trying to find
the best flow we're going to start with
any flow and then we're going to try to
make the congestion smaller so if we're
already routing the right demands then
then you want to keep reading the right
demands you add a circulation so that's
what our setup is going to be this is
just how a power tries things is start
with any flow fix that in advance now
we're going to look for the circulation
to add to it to make the infinity Norm
small
um and you know constraints are
unpleasant and so we're going to do is
we're going to turn this into an
unconstrained problem so rather than
you'll notice here the such that is a
circulation uh it could intersect
weirdly with the infinity Norm you know
there's a box and a hype and some
Subspace and that could get complicated
so we're going to do instead is we're
going to try to do an unconstrained
Problem by defining a projection Matrix
so so that we can then uh well give me
three lines and then I'll say this more
carefully but we're going to define
something to be a circulation projection
if it is a projection into circulations
so what that means is I'll give you an M
by m Matrix so it takes flow it takes
things in flow space to flow space edge
vectors to Edge vectors
um it's a and has the property that if I
apply it to anything I get a circulation
so projections to linear space of
circulations
and has the property that it is a
projection which means P Squared is B so
if I start with a circulation and then
apply it to the circulation I get
another circulation back
um the good news about this was that now
um instead of solving a constrained
problem I've sort of converted to an
unconstrained one because now I'm
minimizing the infinity Norm of f plus
PC so instead of forcing it to be a
circulation I'll just project into
circulations and parametrize to
something unconstrained which is just
more convenient
um I should kind of uh oh I want to
briefly stress that this is there's
something a little subtle here usually
when you think of projection matrices
you think you would have thought I'd
write the projection Matrix and there'd
be one of them note that we are not
requiring it to be a symmetric Matrix
there is one symmetric projection Matrix
uh there are a lot of projection
matrices right so this is just any
linear operator with those two
properties and if P were equal to P
transpose we would just that would be
orthogonal projection uh that's not what
we necessarily have and in fact if we
had that we'd basically be back to the
electrical flow setup
um instead we're just requiring it you
can think of it as an oblique projection
this was my attempt at a picture which
was that you're projecting but you're
projecting is not necessarily orthogonal
uh you could think of it as you change
bases and then do projection and then
change back but that's not the right way
to think about it
um right so again the point is is that
it's not a symmetric matrix it's that's
not necessarily just orthogonal
projection and exploiting that
difference is crucial because otherwise
you'd get the root ends back that you
had in the first place
if we're going any questions
okay so
that was produced now I claim that we're
almost there yeah
um not really we're going to bound how
uh congested congestiony it is um but
we're gonna I mean sometimes the we're
going to bound the infinity dorm
properties of it uh we're it will be
bound to ball in the sense that if I
gave you unit capacity graphs it will be
poly and everything but we're not going
to like the goal is to exploit the
obliqueness what we're going to bound is
the congestion properties of it so
essentially the way to think about it is
that straight orthogonal projection it
really is solving an ultimization
problem right and here what we're going
to do is we're going to try to
essentially construct the right uh the
right projection Matrix to to come as
close as we can to solving an L Infinity
problem albeit we're actually choosing
an a better L2 minimization problem to
come close to the L Infinity we're still
doing linear algebra you know but we're
we're not going to actually explicitly
care how weakness
if you're talking about projection which
gives you the minimum distance between
what your projection projecting in the
projected object because you don't hear
if two but you still need to somehow
bound this otherwise yes
could find the projection that gives you
a circulation that's basically unrelated
to the right exactly
right so we're going to bound the
properties of the projection the
properties we want are not going to be
um the L2 angles they're going to be a
thing that involves Norms of stuff uh
infinity Norms of things so it could be
the natural thing to do right so you
look at the minimum with respect to the
infinity Norm
yes well we're going to minimize yeah
and sometimes we're going to write uh
right we're essentially going to be
writing the Matrix that minimizes the
worst case Infinity Norm when you do the
production and that's how we're gonna so
give me one slide and then I will say
yes
um so this is a long-winded way of
saying yes
um so the uh so what is it we want to do
so Infinity Norm isn't before it gets
that a little bit of this kind of I know
clean up uh infinity Norms don't have
gradients so they're not good for
gradient descent so we're just going to
smooth them out it's not a big deal I
could have said use subgradient or
something and hope no one called me on
it but instead what we're going to do is
just smooth it out
um the bigger correct the bigger problem
is that the gradient is the wrong thing
to do
um so if I were to actually minimize
Infinity Norm
gradient is going to the gradient of Max
is the biggest coordinate it's in that
direction so if I were to be at a point
like this imagine I was trying to just
minimize L Infinity if I had a point
that was like 100 and then 99.999 and
then a whole bunch of zeros then
gradient descent will say uh decrease
the first coordinate
um that's not great right like you
really want to decrease both the both of
the first two coordinates if you only
see the first coordinate you're kind of
asking for a linear iteration algorithm
because
um you could very you know this will
take a super small step it will just
move this down until it's equal to that
one whereas what you really want to do
is you really want to somehow count the
first coordinate a lot the second one
pretty much as much and the other is not
so much so you want a smoother object
that says take all the almost biggest
coordinates not the biggest ones
um right so that's what we'll do
um
and that's bar smoothing and there's a
standard answer to that some extent
which is soft Max this if you read it
right is the thing that happens in
multiplicative weights methods
um it is the log so it's a little hard
to parse this uh ignore this this is
because we're doing positives and
negatives uh we want to we don't want if
you look at this you you take e to the
something add them all up and then take
a log that's pretty close to the max
it's just not the max because if two
things like if anything is twice as big
as anything else then when you
exponentiate it it wins and then but if
you were to have a bunch of things that
were comparable then you know you'll get
some direction for all of them uh the t
is the scale fact the T that you're
doing there is sort of choosing how much
to wait
bigness versus like how much to favor
the bigger coordinates okay so that's
off Max
um
and uh T is the thing that makes the
algorithm work you can find the right
you know it's a parameter application
um the properties that it has that are
nice are that it is hand is that it
makes our iterative scheme do exactly
what we want assuming that we have
um a good projection Matrix in a second
right so the properties it has one is
that it's got a nice lip it's constant
to the infinity Norm
um which is that you know so the lip
shit's constant is one over T
um its gradient has a good that fits
constant so that's the property we need
for our previous algorithm
um and uh
so we're going to be parameterizing
things by P times c a little bit of
calculus will convince you that the lip
shit's constant to the gradient if you
just do the chain rule you get that the
lip shifts constant for the gradient of
F0 plus PC is the infinity Norm squared
of your projection Matrix divided by T
so this is the answer this was my
long-winded yes was what we're going to
do the actual thing we're going to look
for is we're going to look for the
projection Matrix P we have this whole
class of them because we get to we can
choose any oblique protection what we
want to do is get the one that's going
to give us the best Infinity Norm
and that's the problem we're going to
solve
um because that's going to give us a
good lipsticks constant and so I claim
that actually I really have other than
giving you any way of constructing a
projection Matrix giving you an
algorithm name like if I were to give
you a projection Matrix with an Infinity
Norm that was n so little of one then
our previous iterative method analysis
tells us that in nth one iterations you
get a poly one over Epsilon
approximation
or and I want to drop some approximation
so in and it's a little of one times
poly one over Epsilon you get an Epsilon
approximation
okay so the recap of all of this so far
was uh L Infinity doesn't equal L2 so
use l Infinity uh projection matrices
are usually oh you know orthogonal
projection is an L2 thing don't do that
instead take an iterative method that's
based on now Infinity then compute the
lip fits constant of your it you know
that determines the running time of your
iterative method and then choose your
projection Matrix to be the best answer
to that so you want to find the
projection Matrix with the best Infinity
arm yeah but there's also a line about
replace some of your Infinity Norms with
s Maxes so I guess I want to get
straight which ones we're replacing oh
so there's two places where Infinity oh
so
uh just to kind of
um okay I should say this a little bit
carefully so the idea was the soft Max
was a smoothing of our original
objective function uh the properties
we're going to use of soft Max are that
we can approximate it and it doesn't
screw up the answer too much
those are distinct properties so
Max is a smooth we smooth our function
our objective function and the doesn't
screw up stuff much we're going to use
to say that if you could actually
optimize soft Max you would get an
approximate answer
um so the well that's the first property
actually is that like you know this
we're adding a smoothing term we're
going to keep the smoothing term less
than the one over up slot the Epsilon
that we're allowed
um and that's so the softmax is just
being done we're still doing actual L
Infinity gradient descent on a smooth L
Infinity ish objective right like so our
objective function is soft Max that's an
approximation of our original objective
that's close enough
uh because of how we choose the
parameter so that it's not too big a
difference
and then the
um and then the that sort of determines
how much that's the smoothing part of it
but then we get to the Lipschitz
constant part of it
um yeah so okay so then we're using
actual straight L Infinity descent
because we're using Straight L Infinity
Norm gradient descent that is the exact
lips that's constant but you know like
or the exact bound coming from the
previous line
foreign
I would kind of hope to save more than
the log which I haven't tried super hard
I'd hope to save the two to the root log
n you know versus login but
um
I don't know Aaron and intent if either
he checked that
the problem is if there is
space so you cannot do mirror descended
right you can't get the accelerated part
of it press that directly it might hurt
the Epsilon which would be sort of worse
right I mean like the natural question
also is can you we have an Epsilon
squared coming from essentially the
there's two epsilons there's the
smoothing Epsilon and the iterative
method Epsilon and there's a hope of
like if you did if you could do mirror
descent as you know with um and
accelerate it for you to accelerate
stuff you actually would hope to get a
one over Epsilon instead of one over
Epsilon squared convergence but Infinity
Norms don't work well with the uh the
acceleration technology
I'm not sure if that's the exact same
technical obstruction but
um it's at least a related one the the
so I don't know how to I don't know how
to shave off
too many of the terms here I expect that
one could do substantially better
comes from making the function smooth
from like wanting it to be smooth and if
you didn't have that so wait that's it
briefly you run into the same
subgradient issue that you ran up with
with the large coordinate that's bad so
you really want to do this smoothing and
once you do that that login comes up
immediately then you have some you have
some choices in this upgrade but yeah
like I mean I agree with Aaron in that
like somewhere you have to do something
smart with the smoothing I mean I guess
there are no way around that but there
are plausibly higher Tech like higher
Tech ways of doing the iterative method
I don't know how to do any of them to
actually get the win but I wouldn't rule
it out
um
wait so just because there's no that
there's no known sub-gradient version of
this that operates directly on the L
Infinity constraint rather than some
smooth zones really constrained um I
mean I could make one that will be
isomorphic ish to this algorithm like I
mean I could make one that meets that
constraint but not with any Improvement
in any parameter
um so not usefully but
um I wouldn't rule out that existing it
prob you know I wouldn't be surprised if
somebody who's a little better on the
that side of the iterative technology
could actually make some of these terms
go down a little bit
um I think that the I the bigger win
which I expect very strongly to exist is
to make these two to the root logins
into logins
but that's just the oblivious routing
part of the
sorry
uh
my rush to write the stock I didn't plug
in my laptop okay so
um
I should okay so let me kind of power
forward a little bit
um this was a reasonably simple
reduction to oblivious routing so once
we have this construct a good projection
Matrix I'm going to speed this up a
little uh because I started a few
minutes late but not enough late that if
I don't speed up I'll get to the end
um so reasonably simple reduction is uh
well I claim if you give me a linear
oblivious routing scheme so nothing in
my Definition of oblivious routing
actually said it was a matrix but we're
going to say it is if I gave you a lot
of beliefs routing scheme that happened
to be linear you can fairly easily
convince yourself that you could use
that to construct a circulation
projection and the competitive ratio is
going to be directly related to the L
Infinity Norm
basically this is what actually will
happen is you take your projection
Matrix is like I minus the oblivious
routing schemes Matrix with
appropriately cast into the right space
so it's just like a one line algebraic
reduction and what you get at the end of
that is you get that the infinity armor
the projection Matrix is the competitive
ratio of the oblivious routing scheme
plus one and again one is much less than
log n so we don't care
so the upshot was that this actually
does reduce us to oblivious routing so
all this iterative stuff end of the day
says that if I could give you a good
oblivious routing scheme efficiently we
would be done
because the iterative Machinery says
that you can now run it a bunch of times
where a bunch is a function of the
competitive ratio
to get a better and better approximation
now the cost of the iteration is bounded
in terms of p and p applying the Matrix
so you have to be able to multiply by
the oblivious routing Matrix you also
have to be able to multiply by its
transpose which roughly corresponds to
Computing the congestion of things uh
you know like you want to Route stuff
with the flow and then you want to
compute the congestion of the flows
roughly so it's a they'll transpose and
the rest of the talk which will be I
think about three minutes given that I'm
an organizer and just should tell myself
to shut up soon
um the rest of the talk will be a sketch
of how to construct the oblivious
routing algorithm that meets these
properties and so the properties meet
are that its competitive ratio is the
promise to M to a little of one and that
you can apply a and a transpose very
quickly
um Okay so
um I'm gonna do this in caricatured
picture because I'm running a little
slow but why the methods were too slow
is that roughly they route with
distributions of trees
um so the way that they were because I
said pad just you know if I gave you one
tree it is a routing scheme so if I give
you a probability distribution over
trees I get a pro I get a another
routing scheme and that routing scheme
is uh plausibly oblivious you know it's
always oblivious it's plausibly good if
you choose the right trees
um the bad signs that you actually need
a lot of trees like you could convince
yourself very fairly easily that if you
ever actually wanted to get a good
oblivious writing scheme you need at
least linearly many trees or else we'll
have a bad uh super logarithmic
competitive ratio unavoidably with
simple examples
um and so the problem here is that you
can't even write down an oblivious
routing scheme in less than linear time
right because there's n edges per tree
and might as well edges portray so if
you need linearly many trees then we're
already past our linear time budget of
running time
um and that's really our issue that's
the main issue we have to get past it's
just that even if we could do all
calculations super quickly we can't even
write down an oblivious routing scheme
fast enough and the solution is to not
write them down and so we're going to do
is instead do something implicit and
recursive
um so instead of multiplying by the main
you know instead of actually writing
down the Matrix we're just going to give
ourselves the ability to multiply by it
um and roughly okay this is where I'll
speed up a little for my last three
minute part
um is we're going to take routing on G
and we're going to reduce it to routing
on simpler and simpler graphs and this
should feel a lot like the linear system
technology so the idea is
um I'm going to give you sort of a
I mean actually skip the notation since
I'm going to speed this up uh okay the
two techniques we're going to give you
are basically I'm going to say I give
you a dense graph and I'm going to say
that if you can route on the dense graph
I'm going to reduce routing on the dense
graph to routing on the sparse graph and
it's going to be roughly using
sparsifiers but we're going to have to
be able to Route the flow so we're going
to want close parts of fires okay so our
first theorem is Edge reduction which
tells that if I gave you so um if I gave
you g some graph G you want to find some
graph G Prime on the same vertex set you
want to find it very quickly and you
want the graph to be sparse this is just
been for carguruptial here but you want
to say that if I gave you an oblivious
routing scheme on the first graph
um you can construct an oblivious
routing scheme on the original graph and
sorry on the I gave you an oblivious
routing scheme on the sparse graph you
can use it on the dense graph
um so that you don't lose too much so
that's our first theorem our first
theorem is that you can take dense
graphs and replace them with sparse
graphs
um and that if I so it's a this is a
reduction it says I give you a black box
routing scheme for sparse graphs linear
then I can construct one on dense graphs
um and then the other piece is going to
be vertex reduction which is going to
say so it's not quite fair to say that
you want to reduce routing on spark on
graphs to graph the few vertices you
actually have to work with distributions
and the property that we want is that I
give you a graph G you want to find T
graphs not just one so that
but this is where the infinity versus
two thing is really different this is
the main Divergence between some of the
linear system side of things and the L
Infinity side of things is that in the
linear system thing you have one sparse
attire here you have a distribution over
them in order to make it work uh that's
like is someone necessary at least and
our goal is going to be I give you uh
graph G and you can reduce it to T
graphs uh so you can reduce it you can
so essentially the idea is instead of
routing over trees where you have n
trees think of as what we're going to do
is we're going to try to instead of
reducing to
and trees we're going to reduce to a
smaller number of graphs that are more
complicated than trees so we're going to
reduce to a small number of graphs that
are trees plus a couple edges
um and then here we're going to say so
here uh what we're going to do to say
that a little more formally is we're
going to say I give you a graph G I want
to reduce it to routing on graphs with M
over T vertices
um and at most damages and I'll give you
T of them and the properties that if I
gave you routing schemes on each of
those graphs you could pull it back to
the original so this is the thing that
writes down what I just said but again
the two properties one is Edge reduction
that says dense M becomes n ish with
reduction uh and you don't pay too much
and then this one says if I gave you a
graph with M edges I can reduce it to
routing on T graphs with M over T edges
um now the reason we need the two is
again the actual proof of the whole
thing is just interleaving these so you
start with a dense graph you sparsified
to get a sparse graph that makes M
smallish so that when you divide it by T
something good happens you then divide
it by T to get T graphs then on each of
them they're now dense again so you
apply the edge reduction and you put
this into a recurrence
um so you repeated and
um slow sparsifier is where our main
tool for doing this I'm going to breathe
past that I want to show you the one
picture I wrote no the main thing I've
left out that actually the main thing I
left at so again the difference between
the standard oblivious routing what I
just said was really just that instead
of using and you need entries but you
only need n over T trees plus T edges or
TS edges
um and so that's what we're going to
take advantage of and then we're going
to do occurrences
um okay so the slight lie here this is
my slight lie thing but it's roughly
true which is that roughly the way we
construct our sparsifiers this is The
Edge reduction part of it is we say that
essentially you figure out how to deal
with expanders the answer is sort of
electrical flow because electrical flows
are nice and expanders and then you
reduce everything to a bunch of
expanders
um so on expanders use electrical
routing this is my picture for what you
do without expanders so if I gave you a
non-expander this is fairly aggressively
ripped off from Dan and shinewell's
earlier papers you uh take your graph
you break it into a bunch of nice
well-connected clusters that although it
wasn't convenient to rip off because you
guys didn't state it as a theorem but it
was it was intellectually ripped off but
I had to rewrite it or actually I think
Aaron had to Lorenzo had to rewrite it
um one of us had to rewrite it but um it
says you can break a graph g into
well-connected clusters so almost
expanders but not quite that contain
most of the edges so you can remove half
the edges and get a bunch of vlogging
expanders or something
um and then uh you sparsify those and
you repeat
okay so that was first bar suppliers
vertex ones I'm not going to draw I'm
going to say out loud the picture was
essentially if I give you a tree you can
route on it by hand
you know very efficiently if I gave you
a tree plus 10 edges you can collapse
all the pads in the tree to make it like
a graph of size 10 instead of size n
um that was this okay okay
um and anyway to recap this was the
whole algorithm and then I will this
will be my last slide so okay to recap
uh this let me run through the high
level picture because there are a lot of
pieces uh outer loop was you have L
Infinity gradient descent to minimize
congestion uh each iteration is going to
add a circulation to improve a smooth
version of The Objective function
um
that will reduce us to finding a good
projection Matrix uh and then uh the
idea is that you'll find the circulation
by taking your error vectors you know
your your errors and your gradient and
just projecting them with a projection
Matrix so the out the gradient descent
technology was reducing us to um to
constructing a good projection
uh then the name piece was constructed
in a good circulation projection which
by just a little bit of by hand algebra
you can turn into constructing a good
oblivious routing scheme and then
constructing a good Above This routing
scheme sort of recursively simplifies
use flow sparsifiers to reduce dense
graphs to sparse grass and you use
um and then uh trees plus a couple edges
allows you to collapse paths that's the
sort of thing that lets you reduce the
number of vertices put it all together
and you get a Max flow algorithm for
multi-commodity flow I said I get my
last 30 seconds on it you do exactly the
same thing with a different objective
function so you don't have to really
change too much you have to change a
little bit of the iterative technology
you don't have to you can use the same
projection Matrix you slightly you just
start with instead of you start with the
objective function of multi-commodity
flow instead of single commodity flow
you smooth it appropriately
uh you know write down the iterative
scheme and do it right so it actually
and what's nice is you don't have to
start over you can just use the same
projection but with a debtor with a
better smoothing and regularization okay
so
um that's it thanks
foreign